two pounds ago investment welcome back
to some more Denfeld
we start off with a beautiful ball
rolling ball of cutscenes because I just
mean wait that wasn't seriously roll
credits weird audience does women come
for breakfast I was like tacos you like
tacos Wade oh you know who doesn't know
this hot taco lady Samantha oh she makes
them best wait let's see
yes anthers taco no way ever again what
you talking about mr. sinister is going
to kill Samantha destroy all her tacos
now my tacos got real indeed so we going
back to back brain style on this one
[ __ ] yeah
no I can't stay I'm fighting my own
values in the future
all of which hinge on what you okay okay
now I get this out anyway the real mr.
sinister is holed up on Magneto's old
Citadel on the far side of the Isle of
that fourth attention days walking [ __ ]
walking for plan awesome alright
but it's plan awesome I am we continue
if you insist on me building this thing
then I'll need two parts my readings
show the first one is no just Jimmy John
Goza may go where
oh here so [ __ ] that shouldn't be a
problem for get out your summers eating
why is he calling summers
what the hell summers thanks good you
all right oh my god do you copy
where did it [ __ ] did he go okay let's
go in the GRT the great shore this
bratty called teenager what
don't miss Erica haha that's Sentinel
part thingy we need ah right get it I'm
sure nothing bad will happen
oh this is like must be another power
seller [ __ ] power this Sentinel heart
more than in tint darkness thanks for
the hint Deadpool just cuz I don't know
where the gold doesn't mean I'm not a
bro
I just want to flap my trombone you
never slept that trombone oh I don't
blame ya it's pretty hot oh oh oh here
we go browse they tour this island apart
killed William ah he will be such a
downer why would he kill people hi [ __ ]
it let's get the thing in the thing
biggest thanks yeah
all right interact maybe now we can like
oh but come on maybe there we go thank
you
finally bye guys I would love to hug
each one of you sexually hopefully we
can reach that oh there's another arm
here I gotcha
I got conveniently placed of course
let's pull some strings
amazing I see it de leus mood strikes
again so [ __ ] boy I'm just too smart
too small for goddamnit
nevermind okay edit out outfits and
that's how we know it let's get this
piece of crap goddamn fapping excellent
you're one step closer to your demise
why it's another part I need before we
can get started
o ye of little faith
how the [ __ ] does he know on this shape
my ass is always moving I juggle in even
if I'm signing sell alright here we go
the cable just [ __ ] appears on that
Adam well again
again my god
hell yeah well that was fun aah jet pool
three bathrooms zero make that make that
forty ah
Oh what the [ __ ]
transformers what are you doing in this
game get out of here transformers Oh
chief what are you so would why do you
even try that's what happens when you
[ __ ] try really this one I thought it
already had one what
Oh
why not
and looks a lot prettier now
okay looks like you brought a gun to a
judge not a good idea
you don't want to do that [ __ ] really
that's it the random thoughts of care
solvers then here's the last part you
need now let's roll up i resection
franchise buddy
Wade this has got to be the dumbest idea
you've ever had
he had some pretty dumb is considerable
this is my dad credit Garrett Wade
what's the Batman what is that his foot
yo dawg i heard you like boots
so i put my boots in this boot so I can
stop you while I stop you and shoot you
make sense
oh nothing bad in dollars [ __ ] good they
die I am happy
how many [ __ ] bad is that are in any
area Oh God
fix the Rama [ __ ] network tryi [ __ ] a
space box and bash oh I said yeah oh
where are they hey guys
Oh No why would that not work
[Applause]
the random pain
things still going according I think Tom
exactly
well it lets him just divert mine now
actually
okay they died anyway
where the [ __ ] did the girl come from
girls don't like that girl like poop in
that poll I learned so much from you
sure were a lot of expensive setups in
that level all the meters okay with the
budget I probably not oh my god it's all
it's literally real house that's the
lamest [ __ ] ever yeah all right let's
look at that full
I mean his girlfriend see I know her
she's famous rogue absorbs the skills
powers memories and anything else
through skin under skin contact
[Music]
like this
wait your rope you can fly Sinister's
here I could feel a nullifying my powers
oh no no no the fighting our powers okay
just take honor of all the bedding Wow
gotta be okay now you're fine
mazie wall dudes again tricky
I hate us Oh gotcha
we too sinister its hands on you
isn't that blockbuster whoo
oh [ __ ]
is it back oh nice I need to find our
arm that - it's the head back up ah
that's [ __ ] haha all the controls are
back I'm trying it's not that easy okay
I think I got it
I think I got it no I don't mr. show
them what's he doing down now I'll make
the Shogun well the mother's good -
that's a good point actually
give it time why do you come come lick
my balls oh no it's happening again
oh c'mon Shree I gotta get you don't go
anyway no way to run ah dang ah much
better
go boy boys y'all go doggy red rocket
now there it is no rope search for rug
in the prison maybe you'll get a kiss
[ __ ] yeah
if I there's a chance of getting a kiss
I'm back where are we going
I'm here ok good right fantastic love it
I don't know looks like some kind of
Genosha
prison prison I was able to read a blurb
about it before someone tore up High
Noon script hey that was cathartic know
why we're still a [ __ ] script that's
what we've been doing whatever newsprint
say Frodo make her fall madly love with
us done happy we're better at improv not
really can't say that
time to work well that lasted not long I
did not laugh whatever English is my
best language why do they have to
explode I mean I'm beautiful but Ju what
is your gift
[Laughter]
haha nice yeah they never peeing games
don't do they I'm gonna wait here this
is quality gameplay yeah how long does
it letting your P's normal right
uh I may be members of a whistle so I
can technically these stairs sir this
forever
good okay I get it never break the guy
code again so I maybe their bag of any
good dick jokes wasted opportunity what
how I'll do it for you that guy had a
dick in his head and that guy had a dick
in his face but um that was not a
goddamn high price I'm gonna end this
episode I hope you enjoyed watching
leave a like if you didn't help me out a
lot and subscribe to become a red today
and I will see you bros in the next one
stay off the bread wrong them out of
sugar
nice [ __ ] robot football here's your
[ __ ] sugar here I'll give it acidity
you want it come on sugar
I gave you